[Music]
male sauce is a very special Mexican
dish it's really the go-to plate for any
major celebration our male sauce started
from just a family recipe but now we are
making about 2,000 pounds of male a day
we never thought in a wildest dreams
that that was going to happen they are
nearly a 1 million Mexicans living in
the tri-state area half of them are from
Puebla where we are from and they still
want the flavor from back home they
select on me the peso come that's what
we eat my family has been produced in
Mali at male verano a la solution for
several years now the business is run by
three generations all of them women my
grandmother my mother and me
Moli just means a sauce with a lot of
ingredients chilies and spices and sugar
in chocolate we also use almonds raisins
and sesame seeds we toast all of those
ingredients up and also have to grind
them as well
that's when we put the pot up and then
we start heating the oil with some
garlic and want some onions and when the
onions and garlic are done that's when
we start pouring our chilies and that's
when we started putting the other
ingredients
you have to have very strong arms to
keep stirring that morning until
everything is completely integrated into
the sauce and so everything looks dark
the our recipe it takes about two days
[Music]
it has to go through grandma to get
approved
no problemo see locally volatile
eponymous my grandmother moved to New
York from PX la pobla in the 1970s
because she had children and mouths to
feed back home
yo yo dat trabajaba yo en la factorio
pero post-american Saval dinero para
pagar Renta YUM perseus LEM pasilla
decir en la vitória no pooja Kamali
americium bueno try Munna Libre yeah my
pony yo a prepare our loco more look
prepare of Messiah in Mexico and then
word-of-mouth starting increasing now
the male sauce is being distributed in
but they got some Mexican stores and
restaurants here New York and the
tri-state area and also all around the
country the longing for a little
something of where you come from I think
played in our success here in New York
City it's a thing thick as it possibly
be the most important part of our day is
at 2 o clock in the afternoon with
have lunch together as a family I guess
it's a very big expression of how much
will our job we love our male and we
love each other and the family I guess
that transfers I'm also in the male so
that will make
you